- [Narrator] In this video,
we're going to study something
called the demographic transition model,
which is something demographers use.
Demographers are people who
study the makeup of populations
and how those transition over time
and why that might happen.
And this model in particular
is one to think about
how a country goes from
being pre-industrial
to post-industrial, and what
happens to the birth rate,
the death rate, and the total population
over time as they make that transition.
And as we'll see, it
happens over four stages.
So let's just first understand
what's going on in this graphic year.
So our horizontal axis
we see is our time axis.
And depending on the
country we're studying,
this might occur.
Oh, in fact, it's definitely
going to occur over many decades,
but some countries still
haven't even gotten
through all of these phases.
So it might've been a century already.
And they might still be
in say this second phase
which we'll describe in
a little bit more detail.
The vertical axis, you can see
it says rates per thousand.
And this is useful for
looking at the birth rate
and the death rate, the
total population here
which is in this light blue color,
that really shouldn't be read as a rate,
that is the total population.
You could probably add another axis here
to measure total population,
but it's telling us indicatively
where the total population is.
Now we see the birth
rate in this blue color
and we see the death rate
in this salmon or this
pink, orange, red color.
And we can see that as a country is,
I guess you could say, starting out,
or really according to this model,
we would call it pre-industrial phase,
which is pre-industrial,
which is this phase right over here.
You have relatively high birth rates
and relatively high death rates.
Why is that happening?
Well, in most pre-industrial societies,
you have a high death
rate because healthcare
is either non-existent
or it isn't that good.
So you could have high child mortality.
A lot of people are dying from diseases
that are easy to cure
in an industrial society
or in a post-industrial
society, which we'll talk about.
And why is there a high birth rate?
Oftentimes, culturally women still haven't
entered the workforce in a major way.
Education generally is at a low level
especially for women at this
stage because fundamentally
of a lack of a healthcare
system for most people,
you might not have things
like family planning.
And so you could imagine that might lead
to an overall higher birth rate.
Now, because both the birth rate
and the death rate are high,
but they're about the same,
you can see that you
have a relatively stable
but we'll say in absolute
terms, low population.
And then countries might
start to industrialize.
And so we call this state right
here the transitional state,
and we can see that at
least on this graphic,
it is elongated and different
countries go through this
in different amounts of time.
You might have a country like Japan
that went through this in
less than half a century,
but you might have other countries
that are still going through this,
even after a half a century
or even a century or more.
But in the transitional state,
this country will start to industrialize.
And this whole model is based on
looking at what happened in
Europe, in the 19th century,
as much of Europe
industrialized and saying, okay,
maybe other countries will
go through the same pattern
of demographics as they industrialize.
So let's think about
what is happening here.
We see that the death rate
is starting to come
down pretty reasonably.
Now, the argument why that would happen
as this country is industrializing
is because they would now
have better healthcare,
they might have better nutrition now.
In fact, that's another reason
why the pre-industrial society
might have a high death rate.
People are even having illnesses
or dying from malnutrition.
But now, because say farm
productivity is higher
because they're able to
use more modern methods,
the nutrition is better,
death rates start coming down.
And birth rates might start
coming down a little bit,
but not as quickly as the death rates.
Now, why the birth rates
might start coming down?
Well, once again, access to healthcare.
More women might be able
to enter the workforce.
You're having a higher level of education
as the society starts to
develop and becomes wealthier.
Now, with the death rate
going down at a faster rate
than the birth rate,
all of a sudden this will
add to the population.
If fewer people are dying than being born,
the population is increasing over time.
And in fact, the rate of
population increase is increasing
as this gap between birth
rate and death rate increases.
Now, the next stage of our
demographic transition model,
we would consider industrial.
And the real marker of that
is we see that in the industrial phase,
our birth rate is starting to
catch up with our death rate.
And so at this phase,
women might be entering
in the workforce in a major way.
Culturally, it is far more acceptable
for things like family planning,
culturally far more acceptable
for people to delay giving birth,
especially for women so that
they could get their education.
And there's just more awareness
that by having fewer children,
the children you do have
will be more prosperous,
will get better nutrition.
The family is overall
likely to be wealthier.
So as the birth rate
and the death rate curve
get closer and closer together,
the rate of population
growth starts to slow.
And then this last phase
right here over here,
the fourth phase in our
demographic transition model
which we could call post industrial,
we see that not only has the birth rate
caught up to the death rate,
that it actually can go
below the death rate.
And so in that situation,
you have a stable population,
but if the birth rate
actually even goes below the death rate,
you can even see the
population began to decline.
And there are societies
that are already there.
For example, Japan has
a declining population,
even places like the United States.
If we did not have immigration,
you would have a declining population
because we are in this
last phase right over here.
And this post-industrial
declining population
because birth rates have gotten so low,
have its own set of issues.
You now have an aging population.
If birth rates are much lower
and people are living much longer,
a higher and higher percentage
of the population is older.
Older people, especially once
they are out of the workforce,
who's going to support them?
Who's going to provide
the healthcare for them?
Where are those resources
going to come from?
If your population is shrinking,
then your economy might
not be growing as fast,
which would make it even
harder to support the costs
of an aging population.
So I'll leave you there.
Once again, this is a
model, it's a hypothesis,
but it's a useful one to
at least have a framework
of how things might transition
in the society over time.
And people use this type of
model to advise countries,
especially ones that might be
in this transitional state.
And the transitional state,
sometimes is the place where
countries might get stuck
because they're getting
delayed economic development.
So they're not quite able
to get too industrial.
And so demographers, economists,
others will think about,
well, how can you make this
transition as well as possible?